i was drawn to stronghold digital mining
because they have such an unusual
approach to uh mining bitcoin
what they do that's so different from
other miners is they take the waste
that's left over from mining coal this
is it's mostly rock with a little bit of
coal mixed in
that these coal miners have just
discarded over decades and centuries
stronghold is based near pittsburgh
pennsylvania
which has a 150
year history of mining the coal that was
turned into
not just electricity but also the steel
that built america's bridges
and battleships and cars and tanks and
try everything and these piles of coal
waste
consist of
literally billions of tons
that are just piled up in mountains in
western pennsylvania and for decades
these mountains of coal waste have been
leaching
heavy metals and other toxins into the
groundwater
and what they found is that
you know there's still a lot of energy
left in these piles and if you have the
right kind
of power plant a very robust power plant
that can handle this material you can
burn it you can turn it into electricity
and sure there's carbon dioxide
emissions involved here
but
what they say they're doing is is good
for the environment because they're
cleaning up
a source of pollution that otherwise
would be
cost prohibitive to deal with so they
get subsidies tax subsidies from the
state of pennsylvania to clean up this
coal turn it into electricity and turn
it into bitcoin
so we are a i think we're the largest
now vertically integrated bitcoin miner
in north america we literally have
tens of thousands of bitcoin miners
which are really the equivalent of you
know computers or servers
we are
i feel the only aggressively
environmental power company
uh in existence we don't just use a
renewable
we actually actively clean up the
environment because we've have have over
230 years of commercial mining in
pennsylvania
and through that time period
they have left an environmental
nightmare on the ground all of the
material that we clean up was brought up
from underground and it's the waste of
coal mining the business was going so
well that earlier in in 2021 they they
held an ipo another publicly traded
company uh stronghold digital mining
their market cap is roughly 350 million
here at the end of the year but a few
months ago they were worth as much as
700 million dollars
the critics of a company like stronghold
would say
you've got to be out of your mind to
still be using coal waste to make a
bitcoin because when they burn this
stuff it does generate quite a lot of
carbon dioxide which
we really don't need any more of but
pennsylvania recognizes that what
they're doing
is beneficial to the people of western
pennsylvania so they
that they can access quite a number of
subsidies for what they're doing
i was really impressed by bill spence's
story of growing up among these these
piles of coal waste he and his friends
would just play on them all day long and
he feels like
this contributed to his cancer and
cancer that that his family members have
suffered as well i
lived amongst them and around these cold
piles
my father had cancer his father had
cancer i've had cancer i directly
attributed to the environment i grew up
on everybody in my family on the male
side of my families died in their 60s
as i was laying in the intensive care
unit it's 59 years old and as i was
laying there i started to laugh i
thought well be careful what you wish
for i'm not even going to make it to 60
years old
so i i've had a pretty significant
commitment
with my life to clean up this waste pile
and be an advocate and from proponent
for these communities we owe these
communities because
they gave so much to america and to the
world i might add i feel that they need
somebody who's lucky enough to be in the
position i am to fight for them and make
a difference people
basically turn a blind eye to the
problem
and we're calling attention to that
problem and we're also making a
proactive obvious effort to clean it up
stronghold is is a really
important example of bitcoin miners
that are trying to find
environmentally friendly ways
to
create bitcoin you know you don't want
to just make bitcoin out of any
electricity you want to use marginal
sources of electricity that might
otherwise go to waste we've already
started to see
bitcoin miners who are trying to use
nuclear power plants you know zero
carbon nuclear power to make bitcoin
but uh short of that it it really does
appear that that using this this coal
waste to make bitcoin
um should be considered a relatively
clean way of
generating cryptocurrency
i'm excited about being part of the
solution
and
you know cryptocurrency bitcoin mining
that's a big part of it and i think
stronghold future it'll be long because
i think the the the problem is decades
to clean up i think there's like
something like 30 years of waste coal
left to clean up
and so
you know we need to think you know even
beyond bitcoin should we be building
this to be a
a multi-use data center and i think
we're we're contemplating now how to be
better and smarter than many of our
competitors might be that are just uh
sort of
you know uni-dimensional um
and i think we're doing it because we
really started as
as reclamation
folks
[Music]